let's play I'm turning oh this is three
plus five so it's quicker all right good
luck
this might be my last game I'm getting
tired I need food and maybe I'll be back
for the future my nervous for tomorrow
what's tomorrow tomorrow I was titled
Tuesday maybe wait no tomorrow's Monday
I don't know what tomorrow is
anyway let's um let's run on sound good
luck to this time I'll actually make a
note so MJ Turner three plus five once
reading 1483 let's click this okay
goodbye to the world
hello to darkness alright let's wait
died just two oh okay you five there we
go
no no three four nights time more copy
catch s so I'm trying to gain time sure
castling it's possible
d6 coming d3 Jesus
you can probably prove move 97 yes we're
playing like a mainline Wow I had
mentioned this line earlier actually
lady 300 the tween that you say Jesus no
this is pure coffee catch us
c3 I'll play there's a five weights
playing well so far
it's probably slightly better - how am i
doing
um c6 put the bishop on c7 probably
might be some d5 idea the bishop goes to
see for let's play Bishop g4 yeah still
pretty symmetrical my idea is not each
for an attack the Knights
if each three I don't know what I'll
play maybe Bishop e6 yeah play Bisbee 6
D for playing oh well I'm glad you find
pleasure from this position D will keep
the symmetry just for you whoever
cheering yeah the structure there's a
III let's play let's maybe trade bishops
you should be sick so symmetrical
yeah we're just treating everything
that's hard to get the advantage so I
bishop on e6 White's Bishop is on I
think a for finally we there's some
imbalance with the structure White's
offering to take and then their whites
offering the trade I don't want to take
though but what else to do
maybe I have this idea earlier night off
for and that all I'll take with the
night probably or what's up on even
maybe I'll take with a pong a few six
pre move
no wait what Oh 95 die plunger upon mmm
I kind of blundered let's play play rook
Apple look after you yeah that was not a
I was not a good move 94 okay I'm
threatening some tricky stuff there's
pressure along efile they both the
knight and the pawn on e5 would be will
be targets that goes back very calm
maybe 93 at some points rook d3 as well
hmm
not sure what to do here try 93 93 my
repeat once
white zero minutes 58 oh man oh that's
that's my opponent two minutes 30 so
that's better okay
rookie - Ricky - 9 - 4 f 4 repeating
once always very easy one rookie okay um
let's try c5 probably not a great move
but it's a move idea maybe c4 what you
5v5 interestings my Knights attacked
take the bishop there's a lady
maybe night 65 65 so I'm just down upon
but okay e5 still kind of the targets
night eat you now I still have 93 nice
night d3 93 b2 is also targets
yeah position still complex
rookie t1 t1 if I take on b2 my night
might get stuck
[Music]
maybe like c7 looks kind of passive
though what else to play that's a weird
position
[Music]
yeah a c7 being safe
I wasn't sure what else to do so
offering the trade of Bishops also
defend my night on on d3 y 0 minutes 23
seconds ones very long time black 1
minute 50 seconds
ok ok v1 okay B 1 so I have a c4 here
play c4 explosive Bishop c2 now maybe
Bishop f5 okay very nice I'll post g4
maybe there's a V 4 V 4 it's a mess but
ok I think I'm winning the pawn on e5
Knight g5 but not yet but maybe a g5
I'll play g6
age 4 ok now I can take the pond5
hitting kind of both nights some respect
age 5 I can take on g5 now here we go
age takes Jesus Brook g4g check King F 1
here 1 let's take what to tick with
maybe maybe the F pawn actually F at the
g6 to open that file wait so what's the
position rooks on be one tasty three do
you one not an e to ever Nancy sudden
let's take with a pawn CD 3 C takes D 3s
make that four do you our ID for also
good move
94 let's play h5 5 man it's gonna be a
tricky on game yeah let's play workout
field
what's material I have three pawns on
the King side there's a pawn enough to
with Holland b7 to b7 nb6 what key to
that's on d4 rookie 5 oh why can i play
with me five wait what indeed you o my
rope goes on g4 okay that's fine d to
play rook F for rook F for oh I know
that was terrible Rick after he was so
bad I meant to play rook F rook
yeah four I'm just down
oh man I'm down a rook that was really
done I didn't specify which rook da da
I'm gonna lose this probably unless a
miracle happens
95 yeah there goes my time kind of 6v6
h4 h4 have to try and fight though
trying to fight for ya g5 let's go g5
a5g4 g4 let's go let's go push pawns
rows n 4 4 h3 h3 this pawn is fast Roby
takes f6 B takes f6 h 2 h 2 my queening
there might be queening Wow well the
plot twists where's the night the
night's Londi for King on I think I'm
teaching rookie four I haven't even 94
oh wait no let's let some that's queen h
1q wait H 1 equal Q how high Queen h1
equals Q how do i Queen h1 q yes there
we go let's go wait where's my knight
about my Knights on f6 okay oh no this
is bad we for is f2 hanging my Knights
on f6 but maybe not rookie for let's
just take my camera my queen Kenji says
Jesus thanks for subbing game III King
III you see one Chuck
three four
oh no doc affort oh that's so so
terrifying
wait King five what's that you know 405
wait King can maybe catch it six seven
King where's my knight I thought my
Knights on that six I guess I don't have
a knight the opponent take it king don't
know king bold why can I move my king
over Kings on we tie the pawn on g7 C oh
there's another pawn um King
oh no I'm creating in the position King
D for D for
Cain takes g7 where's my knight I guess
I don't have a knight qc4 don't have any
Queen sizes no III III I really don't
know what happens my Knights if I ever
look I don't have a rock I have to die
in the corner of sadness Kings before I
have to dirty flag he's fine he's fine
Oh only had so much time we both have so
much time Quincy Quincy 5bb - they're
really just king king and queen versus a
- why can't I move king like King a - oh
my king was on e - that's fine please
just tell me me you need to know I don't
know what was that game of 79 moves my
eyes not used to lightness oh well the
game good game
I'm Jay Turner I don't know what
happened
I got forts 96 was a good move Oh
someone did the oh there Brooke took
uh-oh oh yeah
hired then I got confused why I couldn't
take here
I guess I was so fixated on pushing the
pond I just didn't realize what what
he's doing okay
just just for King Artie Kong and on all
the other people who want it on YouTube
I'll put this on YouTube YouTube people
hope you enjoy that don't laugh at me
too much and I'll see you in the future
and say hi to the twitch chat to twitch
chats that's hi look at the twitch chat
saying hi YouTube look look say hi back